THE CREEPIEST PAINTING FOUND IN
THE SKY NEW MEXICO'S RANCH AND I
MEAN CREEPY.
NOW WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, NOTHING BUT AN
EXTENSION OF THE PRESS OFFICE OF
THE DNC.
REMEMBER FIRST IT WAS RUSSIA,
STORMY, THEN IT WAS IMPEACH,
WHILE THE HYSTERIA SHIFTED, THE
GOAL REMAIN UNCHANGED.
DESTROY, BLUDGEON THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY, UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THEM ALL THE PREVIOUS NARRATIVES
ENDED IN FAILURE, THEY ARE
TRYING SOMETHING NEW AND TELLING
US WHAT THEY ARE DOING LED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AFTER FIRST
DEDICATING THEIR ENTIRE NEWSROOM
AS THEY SAY TO THE CONSPIRACY
AND HOAX.
NOW "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
SHIFTING THEIR EFFORTS TO PAINT
TRUMP AND EVERYONE IN HIS ORBIT
AS A RACIST.
THIS IS NOT A REVOLUTIONARY
CONCEPT, I HAVE CHRONICLED ON
THIS PROGRAM EVERY TWO OR FOUR
YEARS, THE LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY
WILL ACCUSE REPUBLICANS,
CONSERVATIVES OF BEING RACIST,
SEXIST, MISOGYNISTIC,
HOMOPHOBIC, THEY WANT TO KILL
CHILDREN, THEY WANT DRAMA AND
GRANDPA TO EAT DOG FOOD AND CAT
FOOD AND THROW THEM OVER A
CLIFF.
AS WE SPEAK AND THE DEMOCRATS
AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE ALREADY
BREATHLESSLY ACCUSING TRUMP OF
BIGOTRY, RACISM, EVEN
ANTI-SEMITISM, THE BIGGEST ALLY
IN HISTORY FOR ISRAEL IS
DONALD J. TRUMP.
THESE PHONY CHARGES ARE COMING
FROM THE SAME DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT IS THE HOME TO TWO OF THE
MOST VEHEMENT ANTI-SEMITES TO
EVER HOLD PUBLIC OFFICE.
THAT WOULD BE CONGRESSWOMAN
TLAIB AND CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR WHO
ARE OBSESSED WITH HATING ISRAEL.
THEY BOTH SUPPORTED THE
ANTI-SEMITIC BDS MOVEMENT, A
BOYCOTT OF ISRAEL AND THEY
COMPARED A BOYCOTT OF ISRAEL TO
A BOYCOTT OF NAZI GERMANY.
THEY BOTH NEED AN EDUCATION
ABOUT THE HORRORS OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE HOLOCAUST AND
WHAT HAPPENED IN THOSE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THEY SHARED THIS ANTI-SEMITIC
CONTENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA
INCLUDING THAT CARTOON FROM A
HOLOCAUST DENIER, CAME IN SECOND
IN ON A RAINY AND CONTEST.
THEY WERE ALSO BOTH BLOCKED ON
ENTERING ISRAEL ON A TRIP
PLANNED BY A RADICAL ISLAMIC
GROUP THAT PRAISED SUICIDE
BOMBERS AND CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR
CLAIMED LAWMAKERS WERE
CONTROLLED BY JEWISH MONEY.
SHE TWEETED ISRAEL HYPNOTIZE THE
WORLD, MAY     ALLAH AWAKE THE P
WORLD, MAY     ALLAH AWAKE THE O
WORLD, MAY     ALLAH AWAKE THE L
WORLD, MAY     ALLAH AWAKE THE .
IF TO TOP IT ALL OFF, THEY ARE
GOOD FRIENDS WITH THE VILE
ACTIVISTS, LINDA SARSOUR.
SHE SUPPORTS SHARIA LAW AND
BLAMED HER BAD REPUTATION ON THE
JEWISH MEDIA.
TONIGHT, A SIMPLE QUESTION TO
ALL THE DEMOCRATS, ALL OF YOU IN
THE MEDIA MOB ACCUSING TRUMP OF
ANTI-SEMITISM, THE GUY WHO
RECOGNIZED THE SOVEREIGNTY OF
THE GOLAN HEIGHTS AFTER SO MANY
OTHER PRESIDENTS PROMISED TO
MOVE THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM --
THAT DONALD TRUMP.
YOUR ACCUSING HIM OF
ANTI-SEMITISM, WHERE'S YOUR
WIDESPREAD CONDEMNATION OF THESE
TWO CONGRESSWOMAN?
THE LEFT'S ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
TRUMP, IT MATTERS IF HE DOESN'T
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE, THAT
SELECTIVE PHONY OUTRAGE -- IF
SHE ALIGNS HERSELF WITH RUSSIAN
LIES, THAT'S FINE.
DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
IT'S A SHAMEFUL DISPLAY OF
HYPOCRISY AND A DOUBLE STANDARD.
JUST TODAY AND EDITOR FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS FORCED
TO APOLOGIZE FOR A TWEET HE HAD
SENT OUT IN THE PAST THAT WAS
ANTI-SEMITIC AND RACIST AND
DON'T FORGET THE TIMES WAS
FORCED TO APOLOGIZE FOR
PUBLISHING A HORRIBLE CARTOON
PICTURING PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU IS TRUMP'S
SEEING-EYE DOG.
WE JUST LEARNED THAT MANY 2020
DEMOCRATS CALLED FOR A BOYCOTT
OF UBER AND LYFT, THEY SPENT
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS ON THESE CAR
SERVICES EVEN ON THE DAY THEY
PROPOSE THE BOYCOTT.
THIS CAME FROM BERNIE SANDERS,
THE ANGRY SOCIALIST HIMSELF,
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO HE UNVEILED
HIS VERSION OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL AND THE CONTENTS ARE WHAT
YOU WOULD EXPECT FROM A
77-YEAR-OLD ANGRY SOCIALIST WHO
HAD HIS HONEYMOON IN THE
SOVIET UNION.
NO MORE OIL AND GAS BY 2030.
MAGIC PLANES THAT DON'T EMIT
CARBON AND AN END TO ALL
UNEMPLOYMENT, GUARANTEED JOBS
AND THE WISH LIST GOES ON AND O
ON.
SO DOES THE BILL, HOW DOES THAT
GET PAID FOR?
ITS 16.3 TRILLION WITH A T,
DOLLARS.
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL BUDGET IS
4 TRILLION.
SANDERS CLAIMS THE PLAN IS GOING
TO PAY FOR ITSELF WITH TAXES ON
OIL AND GAS COMPANIES, REDUCED
MILITARY SPENDING AND A VAGUE
PROMISE OF MAKING CORPORATIONS
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
CAN I JUST PUT THIS IN CONTEXT?
IN 2018 AMERICAN OIL COMPANIES
MADE A PROFIT OF $28 BILLION A
YEAR, THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY BUT
THE ENTIRE BUDGET FOR THE U.S.
MILITARY IS LESS THAN
$1 TRILLION.
IF YOU DO SOME BASIC, SIMPLE
MATH, YOU WILL FIND OUT THAT
BERNIE IS ABOUT $14 TRILLION
SHORT OF HIS GOAL.
IF YES WHO'S GOING TO PICK UP
THE BILL?
HE IS GOING TO ATTACK THE OIL
AND GAS COMPANIES, CORPORATIONS
DON'T PAY TAXES, THEY PASS IT ON
TO US.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF BERNIE SANDERS BECOMES YOUR
PRESIDENT, YOUR INCOME WILL
DISAPPEAR AND SO WILL THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY, IT WILL DIE
INTO A DEPRESSION, PROBABLY
IMMEDIATELY IF WE GET RID OF OIL
AND GAS.
IF ELIZABETH WARREN GETS HER
WAY, THE MONEY SAVED UP IN THE
BANK IS ALSO GOING TO BE SUBJECT
TO A GOVERNMENT CONFISCATION TAX
CALLED THE WEALTH TAX.
THEY HAVE ALREADY TAXED TO ED IF
YOU ARE STUPID ENOUGH TO SAVE
ANY MONEY OR LUCKY ENOUGH, THEY
WANT ANOTHER BITE OUT OF THE
APPLE CALLED THE WEALTH TAX.
THEN WHEN YOU DIE, THEY'RE GOING
TO TAKE MORE, 40% OF WHATEVER IS
LEFT.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT CONRAD
BILL de BLASIO, THE MAYOR IN
NEW YORK, WHILE HOMELESS
AMERICANS LINED THE STREETS, HE
IS NOW DEDICATING PUBLIC
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CAN ACCESS PUBLIC
HOUSING IN HIS CITY.
THIS ALL COMES AS CREEPY, CRAZY,
SLEEPY JOE BIDEN BARELY CAN DRAW
A CROWD ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" TOOK